if you want to reach 150 million people
and use 20 people to get there in a very
very fast bike manner you can use us I
constantly I betcha
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
roughly seven to eight of us live in
this house full-time so you like raise
your hand if you live as well it's just
always random we don't like check our
DMS we don't just do that like it's
always through this person we randomly
met this person then it just work we
just look through ticked-off and we find
someone with talent the last person that
we added was I think like a week ago now
his name's Larry everybody know my name
when I come Alex brought into the house
for a collaboration for his own channel
and then we'd all started talk to him
and we're like this kids like really
cool he's talented he works hard so a
week ago after a month and a half I'm
getting to know him
we've just put him on the team Larry you
are so funny you are hilarious one of
the biggest things we're looking for was
creating something it was not just a
business we all came together as friends
in the beginning and our biggest role we
added new people was vetting them along
like do they get along with everybody so
we have a really good family bond here
and that's like one of the things that
makes is really special
we get along if we don't buy then it
kinda just doesn't end up working out
and like we want to actually enjoy them
in their company because I feel you can
tell through camera if people like each
other or not and like it's not fun to
fake things it's not just a group of
friends
I literally treat it like family you
know we argue we fight we have our
differences but at the end of the day we
all go to bed we still love each other
so that's kind of like and we fight a
lot but it's like we're a house full of
teenagers doing something that's not
traditional and we started this as a
group of friends to make content to have
a good time to do something that no one
else is doing and it's working out
really good and it's really fun and they
were making a business out of something
that we've dreamed of doing this is what
we fight about you stole my tweet about
it who's a better cook nobody really
cooks we eat out probably like 15 to 20
of that yeah yeah that person orders
yeah
[Music]
little guys and girls share room - yeah
it was really easy actually in the
beginning because we just we set the
rooms up based off of people that had
the closest like connection or were like
closer friends it was pretty simple the
rent for this whole house of eleven
thousand five hundred dollars it's all
split by room and then depending on
who's in there whose days are the most
then you split it up it's also like if
you one of the two of the bedrooms
connect and they have a balcony so it's
like you have extra space or like one
about one bedroom doesn't have a
bathroom in it so you have to like use
some else's bathroom so it's all based
on like what's in that room and what's
it connected to it and everything just
like knowing that these people have your
back you know like we're all in this
together and like this is obviously like
a risk like what we're doing and so like
knowing that no matter what like happens
in this we all have each other's backs
and we're all like really good friends
and we're not if family if you will but
like we're not afraid to like stand up
for each other and like if something
goes wrong you know like we're there for
each other and with that hate of social
media like it's always good to have
people that have your back and like our
willingness stick up for you and like
come for you in those times so like I
think that's the best part is just
knowing like you have a solid foundation
of people that love and support you and
like have the same dreams and goals as
you and are like willing to do those
things to like get there we all do it
together
and I think we love that we have so much
trash nowhere to play and also as we are
it's living with this many people you're
gonna run into the mess so it's there's
no living in the house with this many
people coming in and out it is it is
it's not possible for us all to clean it
up and even if you do pick up after
yourself then we have an abundance of
trash and then if you have too much
trash that that people come pick it up
because we can't have like a huge
dumpster in a residential neighborhood
like this so we have people that come
and pick up the trash and we have people
that come and like just get it all out
it's just it's just an expense that we
all split also there's a lot of like
jealousy not about not in our group of
people but other people on social
they just hate us for no reason because
we do well and we're really nice and
we're really open everyone and we like
we don't tell anyone they're not allowed
to come here like we're we're like come
in like come work with us like we're
super happy to do that with anyone and
for some reason people just don't like
that
we haven't someone tweet about us being
like they didn't suffer enough to get
where they are and I was like that's
enough I know I was I got so sweet to it
our big thing is like we just avoid that
feel we've never said a bad thing about
anyone online we won't like it so it's
not our place more like standards like I
like you know if you're gonna be in this
house we want like hard workers people
that are actually like caring about
their content and like putting their
best foot forward on the internet we
want to be a collaborative house where
people can come over and feel
comfortable making content here instead
of like a frat house with you just throw
parties Allister
it's easy to make three videos out of
there at least I like excuses I yell at
everyone to get to work and then it's
like oh you like you you live in a
mansion with your best friends and you
couldn't post a tik-tok today why are
you here you just didn't know we like
them we just try to push each other as
best we can because like this is
something that is we're very lucky to be
a part of and we are we work hard for
especially like a lot of us have put a
lot of work into this business and the
hype house into everything to grow it to
where it is today so it's like we have
to maintain that we have to grind
towards it we have to like be and
understand what we have and take
advantage of it while it's here
get them out for like a single pose
great probably up to 30 $40,000 on the
tick-tock if you're very big yeah how
many took that's all what you're doing
10 to 15 minutes take anywhere from like
yeah sometimes 30 if it's like a really
good dance yet if you go on the top
tarts on iTunes and Apple music you'll
notice they're all tank top songs every
single one yeah and we've like run music
right now
[Music]
when a new album's coming out from an
artist they'll reach out to us and
they'll supply us with that track and
they'll say hey we want you guys to
promote this we have this budget take
your creators and then they'll do the
song and do the dance and then promote
it every day
people are trying to come to this house
because it's if we can reach that many
people if there's videos getting 30 40
50 million views of someone dancing on
tik-tok that is 30 40 million years to a
year song and that's worth a lot more
than radio is these days or a billboard
is these days wow house so if you want
to reach 150 million people and use 20
people to get there in a very very fast
like manner you can use us there's a lot
of artists that want to come over
trying to get postable and trying to get
rich the kid the only hours will be
crazy trying to get Drake the those are
people that it's also gonna legitimize
us as a business it's like oh they're
actually working with some of the
biggest artists in the world like this
isn't just oh they're just doing this in
their room like that we're trying to
establish that as war and get people to
know us past just our 15-second videos
Kourtney Kardashian has fought the Sun
Paul was like all of us which is pretty
crazy
kendall Jenner just recently joined
tik-tok yeah follow me
this group is so diverse and it were not
just a bunch of tick tock errs like
there's you know real dancers and
there's Daisy who models and then
there's Alex who does YouTube and then
there's us who do tick tock you know
like and we're getting into acting too
and it just opens up so many doors it's
just like it's crazy how much it's done
for all of us and like such a short
amount of time works and how it comes we
go so we're thinking already ahead like
investing in stuff like real estate or
like stuff like that we're not gonna we
know that it comes and goes
I have an account where I put over like
half my income into and my uncle is the
financial advisor so he helps me just
invest all that so like I am definitely
planning for like the future because I
know like how much all our kids class
[Music]